when europeans turn on their radiators
or hit the light switch they expect
reliable and affordable energy to bring
them heat and light
that confidence is flickering as energy
prices soar
faced with calls for a bold response the
european union says it will examine the
way its power market is run and will
consider calls to revamp regulations
however the eu insists its plans to
tackle climate change must stay on track
winter is coming fears of the impending
temperature drop in the northern
hemisphere have driven gas prices to
record highs
since the start of the year prices have
surged at chilling 670 percent
spaniards are struggling to pay utility
bills and madrid wants the eu to make
group purchases of gas much as it did
for vaccinations for covet
greece wants an eu fund to help
governments weather the crisis
however other countries led by germany
and the netherlands urge caution
they argue the energy crunches short
term and related to the unprecedented
supply shock following the coronavirus
pandemic
some members fear the energy crisis
could lead to social unrest and should
take priority over combating climate
change
but the eu's climate chief franz
timmerman says there's no alternative
the levels of social unrest if we leave
the climate crisis untackled are going
to be unsupportable our children will
wage wars over water and food if we
don't tackle the climate crisis and of
course tackling the climate crisis also
leads to a number of difficult decisions
a number of big changes but let's keep
our eye on the ball the problem here is
the climate crisis and we need to act
quickly and europe needs to lead so that
the rest of the world understands where
we need to go
next week the european commission will
propose measures aimed at easing the
price surge for consumers
and making sure europe's kettles don't
go off the boil
and for more on this i'm joined by leon
izbiki he's a natural gas analyst with
energy aspects leon thank you for coming
on to the show um i want to start with
what happened yesterday when we saw
prices explode wholesale gas prices
explode what exactly happened
well i think you know that's a good
question ultimately the market has
become untethered because we have blown
through the traditional capsule to speak
on gas prices which are usually the gas
to coal switch and after that we have
also blown through the gas to liquid
switch so ultimately the market
was trying to find a level at which
there was further price resistance in
this case probably also from shedding
industrial demand for natural gas but i
think also it's important to highlight
that ultimately there is also a large
amount of speculation in the market and
this speculatory bubble really
was set to burst yesterday
remind us why are some countries more
exposed to these spot market rates than
others
so
ultimately this is a question of the
amount of stocks that you have in a
country and also
fundamentally really how much you could
actually fill up those stocks over the
last summer so the countries that we're
seeing particularly in northwest europe
uh having historically very low stocks
such as for example germany and austria
are essentially going to drive up that
price in the ttf in order to
further free up natural gas demand in
order to bring that into storage
you know member states are looking at
block purchases as a solution some of
them are we should say
is that a reasonable solution that the
eu does something with gas sort of like
what it did with vaccines this idea of a
purchase for everyone
uh i think it certainly is but i mean
the fundamental question is what
european policymakers can really do in
the current situation and fundamentally
also where they are going to purchase
that gas from because asia is showing no
signs of essentially losing the price
war with europe that is bidding for lng
cargoes and simultaneously there is also
this underlying question of whether
russia can actually increase flows to
europe so while it is
a good thing to think about
fundamentally purchasing gas on block
the question is where is that gas coming
from
there's been a lot of criticism that
russia hasn't delivered as much as it
needs to in a crisis um how do you see
it have you been able to look and see
what they have been delivering
well so fundamentally i think it's
important to highlight that ultimately
on a year-on-year level russian flows to
europe have increased but they are still
below
around 18 below pre-pandemic levels and
this happens in the context of where
we're actually seeing gas demand in
europe grow overall around three percent
compared to pre-pandemic levels so
russia has been meeting nominations on
the european gas market
but i mean fundamentally also
the the initial problem is
that russian production has increased
but a lot of that production actually
flows into the russian balance itself as
the country is looking to fill up its
law storage all right leon izbiki with
energy aspects thank you very much
thank you
all right dw correspondent in brussels
marina strauss joins me for more
marina good morning um so we hear that
the eu is encouraging member states to
provide relief to their citizens to try
and offset some of these rising prices
but is brussels itself prepared to do
anything
well in this case it's urging its member
states and sweden member states to help
small businesses and consumers because
these short-term measures is something
the single member state states have to
do themselves but in the longer term on
eu scale we saw that in the report some
eu member states for example france and
spain are asking for a change of the
rules that are governing the eu's energy
market for example spain
suggested this strategic gas reserve for
the whole of the eu
for emergencies
and wednesday next week the eu
commission will present a toolbox of
medium and long-term measures
so we have to wait a bit and see what
kind of ideas they come up with but this
clearly shows there is a political will
to tackle this issue here in brussels
and marina we also heard yesterday that
hungarian leader victor orban
made a connection between rising prices
energy prices and the rising cost of
carbon emissions in the eu the eu of
course covered by that emissions trading
scheme now those prices have risen
somewhat they're not as dramatically um
what do eu leaders say to that kind of
connection that he's putting there
i talked to franz timmermans
the commissioner or the vice president
of the eu commission who's responsible
for climate we saw in the report and he
told me yesterday that
according to the commission this is not
correct so he said that those measures
are only responsible to a very small
extent a maximum of one-fifth he said
and he claims that putting a price on
co2 emissions is not the problem but the
fact that the the market demands are on
an all-time high
due to eu economies coming out of the
covet 19 crisis and as other eu
politicians he says that the quicker the
eu switches to renewable energy sources
the quicker eu citizens are protected
from these uh energy spikes we saw in
the last couple of weeks
all right marina straus cw correspondent
in brussels thank you very much
now as we mentioned earlier european
countries are certainly not alone in
their struggles with energy supply india
is facing a crunch in coal following a
surge there in demand
now energy suppliers have recently added
over 28 million consumers in india
mostly lower and middle class and poor
who are buying goods like fans lights tv
sets
now it's not just soaring demand recent
monsoon rains flooded mines and
disrupted transport and that helped send
coal prices up sharply for power
stations
a coal generates nearly 70 percent of
india's electricity
three-quarters of which is mined
domestically
state-run giant coal india produces most
of the country's supply and says that
it's now on a war footing to ensure
deliveries
but supplies for more than half of
coal-fired plants are at a critical
level delhi says that it's even
considering rebooting idol power
stations now for more on this i'm joined
by dw correspondent charlo kartakai in
studio delhi achara good to see you um
how serious could this situation get for
businesses and families uh in india
good morning stephen it's an anxious
morning for uh officials of uh the power
ministry in india because uh the
situation appears to be very critical as
of now there are 135 coal powered power
plants that the regulatory body
monitors and out of these at least 16
have zero days of stock which means they
have completely run out of stock
on an average these plants have been
left with about four days of stock so
that's a pretty uh critical situation at
this point of time businesses are
definitely scared for households it's
not really uh uh they do not really
appear a bit perturbed because india
these kind of blackouts it's a very rare
phenomenon last time india had a
blackout it was in 2012. it was pretty
scary though because uh
about 400 million people were affected
on day one and another 600 million on
day two but that was uh nine years ago
and uh of course memories are still uh
very uh uh alive of that blackout but at
this point of time it is being ruled out
that we are heading towards that kind of
a situation again
char how is the indian press looking at
this for example is this an issue do
they see an issue here about energy
diversification in india did they see it
about green policies did they see this
uh relating to the pandemic how's it
being handled there
it's all these things combined steven
one is of course uh the pandemic had led
to a fall in demand so probably uh the
authorities had gotten a bit uh like a
daisical about how to manage the supply
because post pandemic there's been a
surge in demand even though industrial
activity is yet to pick up so this is
mostly household demand as you rightly
mentioned in the introduction that 28
million households have got new
connections so the consumption has
definitely
gone up but of course yes this is a
problem with india's energy mix as you
rightly said some estimates suggest that
coal accounts for about 70 percent of
india's energy mix
we've been trying to go ahead with solar
and increase our dependence on solar but
that hasn't been working out very well
there are some estimates suggest that uh
this month the uh the the growth in
solar output has fallen by about 40
percent as compared to uh on a
year-on-year basis so solar is not
really achieving its potential and which
is further increasing our uh
dependence on coal
all right but many accounts a bad year
for renewables character in delhi thank
you very much